[Music]
my next guest is four foot five but he's
a giant on the basketball court at just
11 years old he's the star point guard
on his high school's varsity basketball
team is ranked number one in the state
of Florida in assists please welcome
from Orlando Julian handles Neuman thank
you for being here yeah you flew all the
way in from Florida it was very nice of
you congratulations you got to tell us
these videos on YouTube of you playing
are absolutely extraordinary how old are
you now you're 11 and how old mean you
started playing basketball
seriously Wow 3 3 so you were 3 and you
just started and where did you get the
nickname handles they started calling me
that cuz I can join the ball well oh
they just call you handles because you
you handle the ball well I'm called
handle sometimes cuz of a layer of fat
above them it's not as great you're 11
years old now fifth grade and you're on
the varsity team that's just completely
unheard of what position do you play
um point guard I lead the state in the
state of Florida assist and second in
the country that's incredible
[Applause]
now you are 4 foot 5 inches
how tall are your teammates 5 9 2 6 4 so
you're playing with geyser 2 6 4 and
sometimes you're playing against guys
that are 6 4 is that right yeah 7 6 you
you've played against the guy that's 6 7
what is your strategy when you're your
height and you're playing against
someone who's 6 4 6 5 just to use my
quickness and to go by them my quickness
just dash by them with your quickness
that's that would that works for me
we have a picture here of you with your
team to check this picture
[Applause]
Julian I did they have a uniform that
fit you when it was time to pick out a
uniform for the varsity team I had to
roll it out like Herod sighs hey you're
using hair ties after my shorts right
but it works right it doesn't matter
that's absolutely incredible
okay it is your family tall you have a
tall family do you think you're gonna
have a growth spurt at some point you're
gonna keep going but what do you think
is there a chance for you to be
six-three six-four six-five too good
does it sound like you need it though
you're doing great without I don't think
I don't think you need height you've got
speed you've got the moves and you have
a sister who plays - is that right yes
is she older sister younger sister yeah
okay is she good yes you worried about
it when you play one-on-one do you worry
about her why don't you worry about her
[Applause]
in trouble no longer in trouble in Pinal
are bugs sleeping on the couch psychic
today I can go home to my wife hey do
you ever do ever trash talk on the court
I mean you see you're such a sweet nice
kid and I've hung out with you a little
bit today but when you're really playing
you get intense - trash talk never oh
that's good
nothing like that that's good I like
that I like that you're a good
sportsmanship I think it's important you
know I would if I were you but what is
your what is your team record I'm 21 and
6 Wow 21 and 6 that's fantastic who like
your favorite NBA players of all time
um Chris Paul and Kobe Bryant that's
interesting no not what about LeBron
since you're from Florida
that's okay
and LeBron not so much right but Kobe
well we heard that you had never been to
a Lakers game right yeah we're sending
you to one tonight you're gonna go see a
lake again
[Applause]